hello and welcome to
the center for policy studies panel at
the spectators alternative conference
on the topic is is there a free market
vision for leveling up which i guess has
two components is there a free market
vision in the government for levelling
up and
can there be a free market vision for
leveling up and we need what does
leveling up mean uh it's a phrase we
often uh hear quite a lot about um
joining me to discuss this are two uh
great experts on leveling upwards
downwards and in all
in all directions um douglas carswell is
the former mp for clapton and
uh head of the good governance project
as well as one of the uh pioneers of the
localism movement which
made the argument that britain is a
ghastly centralized country and would do
a lot better if we
leveled up and devolved power and sam
bowman is formerly of the adam smith
institute and is now director of
competition policy
at the international center for law and
economics and
we've only got half an hour guys so um i
guess if we just um
crack on with it if you have any
questions please do just uh find them
away by the spectator app
um or even the youtube screen um and um
we'll do our best to
to tackle them and i should say i'm
robert koble i'm director of the cbs
uh founded by this lady here who among
her many uh
talents was not a great fan of uh of
localism really um
and uh is um i mean
although the few challenges that can be
able to get so we're through is that
the you know the the of the reasons
leveling up might be needed is because
um you know crushing the left meant
taking power uh
from from local councils and
centralizing it with that um
let's begin um sam is there a free
rocket vision for levelling up uh yes
there is
and um since i know we're pretty short
on time i'm going to focus on
just one aspect of kind of leveling up
that i think
could make a huge difference and i think
is pretty clearly a free market
uh policy a lot of people think about
leveling up as being about spending
but actually a lot of the um things we
need to do as i think the kind of
localism agenda
might suggest is remove biases that
exist either explicit biases
or more often biases we're not really
aware of that
favor certain parts of the country
especially places like london where i'm
in right now
and disfavor other parts of the country
so i think the biggest bias that we
could eliminate
is the bias against investment in
physical machinery
in the tax code and physical buildings
in the tax code and this is
um really a quirk of the tax system
to do with how we treat business
investment versus other forms of
business spending
so if you run a business the spending
you put into things like rent
things like wages things like pens and
paper you can deduct from your tax bill
today it's a business expense
it's not counted for the purposes of
taxation but if you invest in something
like physical machinery
for factory or in buildings for um
let's say again a factory um you have to
depreciate that investment over the not
the notional lifespan of the investment
and that can take many many years even
decades in some cases
and what that means is that in fact
because of things like inflation
and because of things like the time
value of money the things you could do
with the money other than investing in
those things
in fact businesses that invest in things
like physical machinery and buildings
can only deduct part of the investment
from their tax bill
um in the case of machinery it's about
76 and in the case of buildings it's
about 28
although that changes quite a lot for um
kind of slightly technical reasons
um that fluctuates quite wildly over
time the rest of that money
so about 25 in the case of machinery and
about 75
in the case of buildings is taxed as if
you had drawn that investment as profit
now that's a huge disincentive to that
kind of investment and it's a huge bias
in favor of business activity that's
based on let's say
high skilled workers that's based on um
valuable office space
uh based on the kinds of things that
services and places like london do
really well at
but places like wrecker and hull and
other parts of the country
don't do so well now put this in
international perspective
the uk is 35th out of 36 oecd countries
at this uh uh tax cost recovery it's
called
uh the only country that's worse than
the uk for this is chile
every other oecd country including
france germany
italy canada all of them are better than
we are and some of them are much much
better than we are
and it's actually gotten worse in some
respects
in the last 10 or 15 years so under
osborne and we all know about the
reductions in the headline rate of the
capital of um of corporate corporation
tax
um but to pay for some of those headline
rate reductions
um the treasury made this kind of cost
recovery less generous
so even though your headline tax bill
was falling the things you could deduct
from
uh from that tax bill the things that
would actually count as business
investment were becoming less generous
so some forms of business investment
were becoming worsely treated and more
harshly
uh penalized by the tax system than they
had been before now
evidence from the u.s that's been cited
in a cps paper um
the adam smith institute has talked
about this lots of think tanks are
talking about this
evidence from the u.s suggests that if
you move to a system where you could
deduct
all business investment the same way you
can deduct pens and paper rent
wages if you could deduct investing in
machinery we can increase investment by
17 and a half percent we can increase
wages by two and a half percent
that's a good year of wage growth just
to put that in in uh general terms and
that's
several very very very good years of
investment growth
um and all we would need to do is make
the system neutral
so this would be good i think for um one
reason because i like a neutron tax code
but for a second reason from a leveling
up point of view because it would end
this bias that i've talked about that
favors places like london
and dis favors parts of the country
where manufacturing is or could be a
much much bigger part of output in the
economy
so it's not a it could be quite
expensive in the short term but over
about a seven year period
um it looks as if and i think this is
based on cps calculations
it looks if the system could become cost
neutral or even cost positive
over seven years now normally it might
be difficult to get the treasury to
accept something like this but these are
not normal times
and everybody knows that we need to make
big bold moves
to increase investment and to get the
economy moving again once we're
once we've seen the back of this
pandemic and i think this should be the
top of our agenda
uh we've great for leveling up and i
think um it would make us all a lot
richer
so douglas thank you very much for the
shout outs to the cbs there
um douglas with one tax cut we can be
free or is there is there more so
is there more to leveling up than just
this i mean i i think you know
you you you represented one of the most
deprived um coastal communities in
in the country and which uh you know we
did with something like this
sam sam spoke um very eloquently and i
i've i've never heard anyone
make that case quite so eloquently as
succinctly as
as sam aid and i i don't think any of us
could disagree with with what he said
that
i i think it's worth just taking a a
step back
on this whole question of a free market
vision for leveling up
why are we asking this question boris
won
and created a very successful electoral
coalition at the last election
and discovered to the surprise of many
in his own party that it contained
what you might call some non-traditional
tory voters and supporters
voters in blue collar voters voters in
provincial england and wales not so much
scotland but certainly provincial
england and wales
and naturally the thought was
what can we do to deliver for people
like this what can we do to deliver
not only in the so-called red wall seats
of county durham
but places like clacton which i used to
represent which certainly weren't
traditional tory territory and
i i think one of the things that we
certainly should avoid
doing is replacing
years of what you might call labour
condescension towards those communities
with a form of tory condescension
towards those communities this idea that
you have to
do things for them by by fit the
question shouldn't be you know
how can we eliminate regional
disparities there was a time in this
country when there were no regional
disparities and that was in the middle
ages when you had
um self-sufficient local communities and
everyone was dirt poor
you need some form of regional
disparities and you shouldn't try to
eliminate
regional disparities because that's the
essence of a
of a market system based on
specialization exchange and
you shouldn't try to direct growth the
question shouldn't be how do we
direct growth i think if you did that
you would end up in
very murky water very quickly
the question really should be that how
can we ensure that there is opportunity
as widespread as possible
and that the government doesn't do
things
which unnecessarily um exacerbate
inequalities and i
i think there are some bad ideas we can
avoid doing i mean the idea that
somehow moving the house of lords to
york is going to affect this is a
nonsense
i i think too we've got to be very
skeptical about those who say you know
government should spend money on an
r d research just
ability you know silicon valley on time
i mean i think those sorts of ideas are
also you know matt wrigley whose book is
on the shelf behind me
explains rather beautifully why
innovation doesn't happen by top down
fear
so i think there are half a dozen things
the government should look to do and
they're
all based on the free market and the
first is is localism
all governments talk about passing power
away from whitehall outwards to the town
hall
but they never actually pass control
over the finances
so i think we need to turn v80 which is
a tax that we pay
because we're in the eu we should turn
vat now that we've left the eu into a
local sales tax and the adam smith
institute
which sam worked for is uh a brilliant
paper
written by some obscure author um a
decade or so ago on paying for localism
which explained how how one might do
this
um some people say hang on if you
localize
control over revenue you would
exacerbate regional differences
actually i disagree kovid has shown
quite how a liberal local councils can
be local authorities and regional
governments can be
they're instinctively illiberal giving
them control over tax raising powers i
think would
force them to offer enterprise lower tax
and spend alternatives it would force
some of them
to think differently i'm a big fan of
the idea of freeport the center for
policy studies
um i i i think your your author of a
famous paper on freeports
has gone on to become chancellor of the
exchequer rishi sunax paper on three
ports i think is an
absolute blinder and if the chancellor
is looking for
a way to ensure there is more
widespread economic growth i think he
could look at that paper he himself rage
and make it a reality it's a wonderful
paper full of ideas
about how to stimulate growth and i i
would i would encourage governments to
take that up
and i think generally cutting
corporation taxes is a good thing
um i i sometimes struggle to find good
things to say about the
previous chancellor chance of george
osborne but one thing he undoubtedly did
do
was extend the so-called enterprise
investment scheme
um and we need more of that one of the
reasons why london and the uk generally
is this
hotbed of startups is because rich
people instead of giving
large sums of money to the chancellor
can offset some of that
by in effect investing in startups and i
think if we could see some sort of
regional variant of the
eis scheme that would be great um
infrastructure i'm not a i'm not a
anarchist i think government does need
to do things
and i think it needs to invest in the
infrastructure particularly transport
infrastructure
and do so in a more regionally um
um with a more regional horizon
um planning liberalization you know
we need to liberalize planning so that
areas of the country that are
underdeveloped or areas of the country
that frankly don't
have a lot of retail um or or real
estate
um investment can liberalize planning to
encourage that
it's not something that can be done
centrally we're talking about
liberalizing planning in white
tournament this government
still the same outlook of all previous
governments which is
where can we put the houses if we had
true liberalization
we wouldn't be trying to second-guess
where the development would go
let the localities set their own
planning
policies and um you know i i think we
would see growth in innovation
um we definitely need that there are
other things we could do but i i think
that's a start list finance
free ports cutting corporation tax
allowing
investors to invest in startups and then
liberalizing all those absurd
restrictive rules on
on on planning and if the government
wants to put on a hard hat
and spend money do it infrastructure
is so often related to transport so
often when we talk about transport
we talk about london-based transport
ideas and priorities and schemes
i think we need to think about transport
infrastructure investments
that help cities in the provinces
not just london i think if we if we did
that we could make a huge difference to
to towns and cities
out there across the country yes so um
we we've had quite enough mutual
american already but i should mention
another
cbs report called a rising tide by our
head of business
nick king which points out that you know
the shifting infrastructure to
uh outside of london is not a case of if
it is not a case of sort of
trying government trying to uh tilt the
balance it's a case of untilting a
balance which has already been tilted if
you look at
you know how much has already been given
to london in the southeast it's you know
it's
it's not been a fair fair fight on that
but i want to
come up with a question about you so you
you guys have those
i would sign up to pretty much all of
those ideas i think there is a
definitely a free market version of
leveling up the question is
how much do you feel and you know and
rishi sunak
wrote the book literally wrote the book
on this or the think tank report the
question is how much does government get
it because
what happened after the election is is
kind of what always happens when a party
wins an election that the civil service
looked at the manifesto
and saw it had this word leveling up in
it and you know
and then it you know and every
department decided to try and work out
what leveling up meant
and every department pretty much
concluded that leveling up meant what it
was already doing
so the education department suddenly
decided that leveling up meant
improving education across in various
different parts of the country the
transport department decided
leveling up meant building new railways
in different parts of the country
you know the the in different parts of
the country was all the same
but everyone there was there wasn't a
kind of consensus about about what this
what this meant i mean do you think
there is a coherent vision within
government for what leveling up means
beyond just infrastructure spending
and do you think it is a free market
efficient not not
not yet i would say i mean i think the
fundamental problem that's bedeviled
governments over the past 30 years is a
lack of strategic
appearance so that when you get a buzz
word like leveling up or before that i
think it was sustainability
um these cliches become cliches to mask
the
existing priorities of the government
bureaucracy and nothing ever really
really changed you need if you're going
to have leveling up you need
strategic coherence at the center and
that fundamentally means rewiring the
relationship between downing street the
cabinet office and the treasury
the treasury i think is being the great
force of
of malevolence in a lot of reform
attempts it's this great sort of blob
with delusions of grand jurors to the
extent to which you can engineer social
and economic outcomes
i i think you need to fundamentally
recalibrate the architecture of
government involving those three
institutions
i noticed that countries like ireland
which has a dedicated department that
oversees public expenditure
they not only tend to get better value
for money but i think it means that a
government there can actually
achieve its strategic objectives more
effectively so
i i think if we're going to achieve any
of this we need strategic coherence at
the center
and that means getting the architecture
of whitehall
fundamentally changed and doing so
pretty quickly because
the clock is ticking um if we try to use
the
dysfunctional architecture of government
to achieve any of this
it's just going to be you know it's just
going to be lip service to localism and
lip service to leveling up
sam would you agree um i agree with a
lot of what douglas has said
um to to on your question i i think one
of the problems is that leveling up is a
slightly empty phrase
um i don't think uh you can really
accuse
previous um kind of governments of not
caring about other parts of the country
than london and maybe the things they
did in practice
benefit but we have a great case study
this the blair government
spent until billions yeah
and kind of and like prove definitively
that they top down spending driven
version of
um right and and and and we can't get
away from the fact that london is an
incredibly productive place and
the areas around london and the
southeast are incredibly productive and
it's really really difficult to
make other places you know to take
whales which is 85
of the national average um in terms of
productivity
um it's really difficult to bring it up
to where london is which is 133
of average national productivity you
know there's there's kind of magic
in cities and there's magic in um
agglomeration effect you know the the
economic benefits we get
when people are close together and um
part of
part of the challenge is number one uh
it's really unpopular when you
um point out that i mean in practice
that we care about people not places
you know we should if if if somebody in
an underprivileged town around the
country
would be better off and would like to
move to somewhere like london then often
the best thing for them is to make it
easier for them to move to london
and you know there's no getting away
from that and if they don't want to move
to london if they can't move to london
there's a ceiling
on how much more productive they can
become no matter what we do no matter
you know even if we lived in a kind of
free market utopia
and the second problem is that um
overall growth matters a great deal and
um overall prosperity um often does kind
of there
there kind of actually is a trickle-down
effect uh whereby
you know the rest of the country does
really well because uh in relative terms
because
london and the southeast is really
really productive and rich not just
through tax receipts but through
investment and through
um kind of skills and kind of knowledge
diffusion and things like that
so while the kind of leveling up agenda
is obviously good because it's good to
make any poorer place or a relatively
poor place richer
if it comes at the expense of making a
place like london
um kind of less productive or less
valuable or grow less
then um that could be a bad thing
overall so so it's i mean it's it's kind
of why i at least
and i think douglas did as well
emphasize sort of no regrets policies
um policies that uh help us lift up or
help us kind of eliminate biases
that are holding down places i think are
really really good but policies that try
to
move investment from one part of the
country to another i think could be
really dangerous and really destructive
yes i mean so i mean the reason it's
called leveling up is presumably because
they used to call it rebalancing but
then that suggested that london would
have
like the seesaw would go and london
would come down so you know
leveling up sounds like every everyone's
a winner but yes so yeah so
but i i i'd summarize the first half of
your remarks as as get on your bike but
only if you want to
well sure yeah i mean there's a there
are inescapable economic facts
you know cities are very very likely to
be more productive than towns
which are very very likely to be more
productive than villages um
you know we we might wish that that
wasn't the case but it is the case
um you know from a policy point of view
there are things that we can do to
harness cities you know we can make it
you know focusing on infrastructure that
allows uh people to commute more easily
and more quickly
that's a really great way of increasing
the kind of potential
job market for each person giving let's
assume that people don't really want to
move because they have attachments so
they have kids in schools and things
like that
so there are things like that that we
can do but um it's pretty unpopular to
say that you know the the
theresa may government in its sort of
dying days one of its um
you know big attempts at getting good
headlines was
this the fund for towns and there is
this big fad for
towns in around kind of 2018 2019 they
never really went anywhere and there
wasn't actually very much
very much money there but there was a
clear attempt to kind of win towns over
um and i don't know how popular it would
be to say to tanz look
um economically there's just no way we
can make you as rich as manchester or
leeds
we could possibly plug you into
manchester and leagues better we could
make it easier for people who live
in these places to commute to manchester
and leeds to get you know
depending on where they are to get
better jobs and that might make you
better off
but there's basically no going back to
an economy that might have existed 100
years ago
and often the best thing we can do is
facilitate change rather than trying to
stop
it which leads us very nicely onto a
question from douglas who i
assume is a different douglas who is
watching this um out there
rather than douglas carswell tapping
away uh on the screen which is
uh what effect does does covet have on
this um you know if um
if remote working is causing p if it
will lead into a remote working world if
we're
you know if we're um if the cities are
emptying you know how do
how do we use those choices to inform
state action
douglas c do you want to um i i think
one of the things that covert definitely
tells us is that we shouldn't take
the prosperity that we have in our
capital city london
for granted um a year ago if we'd been
having this conversation
i think we would have tilted far more
towards the idea of
directing growth away from london that
somehow you know
london needed to um have less growth so
others could have more i i hope that one
of the things that covert has shown is
that actually
growth is a very very precious and
fragile thing and it can easily be
destroyed rather than diverted and
rather than doing things to divert it
you can inadvertently just
destroy it all together the reason the
prosperity of a community
is contingent upon the intensity of
specialization and exchange within that
community
big cities are always going to be home
to more specialization and exchange
what we need to do is to facilitate more
specialization and exchange in cities
and remove barriers to specialization
and exchange
outside big cities like london too i i
hope that coverage shows that actually
there are a whole bunch of rules and
regulations
whether it's to do with clinical trials
or or or
whether you can sell pizza on a street
corner there are a whole
bunch of rules and regulations that
frankly we could we could get rid of
and be better off for it but um i i hope
that one of the
consequences of you know london at the
moment is going through a really tough
time
and there's even talk of of london
becoming a sort of economic doughnut
with the center
dying i think that may be a little bit
overdone
but i i don't think we should take
prosperity in london
at all for granted there are plenty of
cities around the world that once
thought that they were financial centers
um by by birthright um venice and
amsterdam and a whole bunch of others
um if we're not careful london could
become
another has been um so i i hope clovid
shows that we shouldn't take anything
for granted
teleworking and and changes and work
patterns
do you know what i i don't really buy
that i
i think um people are making the best of
a bad job
but you know fundamentally for people to
be productive over the long term they
need to meet they need that
serendipitous intervention there's a
reason why google has built its big new
european headquarters
in london you need people to come
together
and to meet and you need that
spontaneity and yes we can do all sorts
of clever things
on zoom and we can talk like we're
talking now but nothing
in terms of innovation productivity
beats that face-to-face interaction
some anything else i mean one thing i'd
say douglas i mean
you're probably right from an economic
point of view but if i'm a political
strategist sitting there thinking how i
win the tour is the next election and
looking at london as a city that doesn't
vote tory
you know suggesting that we should
channel you know
we we we should kind of we we we should
try and support the people in
in the non-cities who don't do vocatory
we would you know that that would be a
fairly logical
course of action you know just if you're
just if you're being do that doing that
kind of cynical
you know you know whatever caches around
let's give it to our people kind of uh
kind of thinking well think of london
like a cash cow in that case
um you know even if the people there
don't vote tory and i think one of the
reasons for that is that it's
really difficult for them to form
families because housing is so expensive
but um even if the people that aren't
voting tory they're
paying for people who do vote tory to
have better lives and go have better
schools and better infrastructures so
they're valuable for that reason um i
totally agree with douglas pretty much
every word for word i'm sorry to say
uh you know i wish we could disagree and
it would be more entertaining um
i think i think i mean kovid will be
over at some point um there are
more than 200 vaccine candidates that
are eleven in
phase three trials um at some point
sooner or later and i think probably
sooner rather than later
covert will be over and um the a lot of
what we've learned will be that
okay teleworking is uh kind of remotely
working is possibly more viable than we
thought at the margin
but for most people um cities aren't
just about working you know cities are
pleasant because
uh they they have lots of culture and
restaurants and bars
and people and you know there will never
be a replacement
for the social pool of people when
you're young especially and trying to
make friends and trying to meet people
that i mean really cities are
irreplaceable in that respect
um but the solution i think i mean it
goes back to the point i made earlier is
make it easier for people to move in and
out of cities when they want to
not when economics requires them to and
if you do that
then i think you probably will have far
fewer kind of conservative voting
um families leaving london and you'll
have less of this kind of
red red city effect and again that's
good for people in
the kind of places that need to be
leveled up because often those people
would like to move to
cities and not just london you know
leeds manchester edinburgh
there are cities all over the country
that are really prosperous and really
great to live in
that it's really difficult to get to
because the rents are so high
and making it easier to um for people to
move to those places
and stay there if they want to i think
would be a huge benefit in terms of
leveling up
as long as we think about people rather
than just places
yeah so it's interesting that um both of
you seem to be saying that
that leveling up shouldn't be about
taking bolster
and trying to you know increase increase
you know
you know increase its slice of the
government pie by
by x percent it it should be about a
sort of economic vision of the country
that thinks about individual opportunity
more
that thinks about connectivity that
thinks about as you said douglas
local control of where you're
you know yeah i mean it can
go ahead after you
okay the reason the reason is that it
can't be anything else um
you know the modern economies are built
on knowledge and skills and ideas
um they're they're you know sometimes
and and to go back to my early remarks
we can hold back the application of
those ideas and we can hold back
um you know innovative new manufacturing
techniques and things like that
but ultimately um the way we get richer
is by coming up with better ideas and
the way we come up with better ideas is
by sitting around with other people and
talking with them and arguing with them
um not just in the office but at the pub
and things like that as well that's
that's really where um that's that's why
um growth happens
and um the the idea that you know we can
reverse that or the idea that that kind
of growth
doesn't have to happen in in kind of big
pools of people
uh where people are around each other
all the time and talking with each other
all the time i think is just
a fantasy um so even though it might be
nice you know
i i love cities but but a lot of people
don't and i know that people would
many people would rather live in a small
town they'd rather be able to walk to
um kind of green fields and things like
that very easily
but that comes at a fundamental economic
cost and there's pretty much nothing we
can do about that
i i know that there'll be conservative
mps over the next few years who
panic to think that hang on if we just
leave this to the free market
we need to be seen to be doing something
every
one of the five elections i i stood for
parliament
to as a candidate in every time i stood
and i
i saw off my opponents um they
always i think tended to condescend
towards voters by saying if you vote for
me i will divert government resources i
will make sure the government
spends more pork barrel politics in our
community
i i don't think it's credible and i
don't think the voters will buy it
i think actually if politicians talk the
language of giving people the
opportunity to do
things for themselves as communities it
is popular
the old idea from the 60s and the 70s
that you vote for people to divert
resources to enrich your community
i i don't think that's plausible i i
think free market ideas
can be popular they can be populist and
they can win
against those promoting more uh
patrician uh patronizing condescending
alternatives
so you've accidentally answered the next
question i was going to ask
on behalf of one of our viewers which is
uh how politically viable are the things
uh other bits of this agenda which are
not about just you know building new
black properties
if you've been looking at british
politics over the past four or five
years the one thing you will
i hope learn is that condescension and
patronizing
politics where people are going to do
things politicians are going to do
things
for other people they're just not
plausible anymore um
there's a huge opportunity here i think
to make
um free market ideas correctly packaged
and pitched
as very appealing to a restless
electorate who just simply doesn't
believe in the the old style top-down
command and control system anymore
but i suppose part of the problem uh is
that uh you know
free market is associated with the idea
of winners and losers
and you know people are in in certain
times people are looking for protection
as much as they're looking for
opportunity i mean how
do you don't associate it with winners
and losers put it
for example if you want to level up
education give every mom and dad in the
country give every mom and dad
in the poorest neighborhoods of clacton
or county durham
the same choices over where their child
goes to school that rich people in
london have
school choice a great leveling up idea
that can be packaged is about
allowing people to improve the outcomes
and the opportunities for their children
now if you if you pitch these things the
right way you can do
incredibly well no disrespect to think
tanks i've written for some
think tanks but um you've got to take
free market ideas
and retail them in a way that is
appealing
and i think you can really do that in a
way that is incredibly appealing
i don't think you should you know the
free marketers shouldn't be afraid of
our own challenges
sam we're always out of time and
anything to add to that apart from
heartfelt
agreement um a final
a final policy that um i really think
road pricing we often think of road
pricing as a thing that
is relevant to london but actually the
thing that road pricing is most good for
is commuters who spend
hours in traffic trying to get to and
from work um
and road pricing that would make roads
float flow freely between towns and
cities
would be probably the best possible
thing we could do for people
who are um not plugged into the the
engines of growth the cities
that are near them because it's just too
inconvenient and too slow to get to them
and so really road pricing is one of the
um counter-intuitively
best policies that we haven't talked
about for leveling up and um i think
as fuel revenues go down as we all move
to electric cars we're going to have to
come up with some other way of raising
revenues
road pricing is a kind of win-win in
that respect
well thank you both very very much i
think the the knowledge and ideas
that have poured forth from you both uh
have shown that there definitely is a
free market vision for leveling up and
let's hope the government uh accept it
thank you very much for watching um i'm
robert kovale please
um follow at cps link tank on twitter
and
sign up to our newsletter and uh do all
the lovely
things that will enable you to get even
more of our brilliant reports
and please enjoy the rest of the
spectators uh wonderful alternative
conference over the next few days thank
you very much